[Musik]
gefährlich nah am krieg nach der tötung
des iranischen generals solivani droht
iran den usa mit vergeltung kostenlos
durch die innenstadt
augsburg steigt als erste stadt
deutschlands in den gratis nahverkehr
ein
vierschanzentournee ausgang offen
der norweger marius lin weg gewinnt in
innsbruck karl geiger muss sich mit
platz acht begnügen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den nachrichten am vierten januar heute
mit norbert lehmann für den sport einen
schönen gruß von mir die welt schaut in
großer sorge auf den krisenherd iran
irak nach der tötung des iranischen
generals sulimani durch eine
amerikanische drohne ist die lage dort
extrem angespannt am abend schlugen
mehrere geschosse in der nähe von us
einrichtungen in bagdad ein richteten
aber keinen schaden an
der iran droht weiter mit massiver
vergeltung und im irak versammelten sich
zehntausende zu einem trauerzug für den
getöteten jörg brase berichtet aus deren
kondolenzbesuch bei der familie des
getöteten generals präsident johann i
lobt kassam soleimani der habe
großartige arbeit für sein land
geleistet und dann droht johanni den usa
die amerikaner dachten wohl sie würden
sich ärger ersparen indem sie ihn töten
das aber war ein fehler ich meine es war
ein großer strategischer fehler
stattdessen werden ihn schwierige tage
bevorstehen
die rams presse giftet gegen die usa die
rache wird kommen titelte die
regierungsnahe zeitung kayhan und auch
viele in der bevölkerung erwarten eine
starke antwort ihrer regierung
ich fühle mich wie ein soldat der seinen
kommandanten verloren hat wir folgen
alle dem wort unseres obersten führers
wie er wollen wir alle dass sein blut
gerecht wird
nicht nur für mich sondern für alle
iraner ist solle man es tut so als ob
man seinen vater und seine stütze
verloren hat in der irakischen
hauptstadt bagdad verfolgen tausende auf
den straßen den trauerzug mit den särgen
der getöteten
viele rufen tod den usa im irak wie im
iran sind man auf rache optionen dafür
gibt es viele
es gibt in der region zahlreiche
amerikanische ziele die sich in
reichweite unserer raketen befinden dann
gibt es die schifffahrt im persischen
golf
und schließlich israel das aber wäre für
amerika sicher eine rote linie
trauerkundgebung auch heute in teheran
ein angriff auf israel so weit wird
irans führung wohl nicht gehen wollen
ein offener krieg mit den usa wäre teuer
und nicht zu gewinnen doch der tod solle
man es wird gerecht werden daran lässt
man in teheran keinen zweifel
unser korrespondent jörg brase ist seit
gestern für uns in teheran jörg was
bekommen sie von der stimmung dort mit
wie groß beziehungsweise wie gefährlich
ist das bedürfnis nach vergeltung
das kommt darauf an mit wem man redet
die teilnehmer aber den
trauerkundgebungen heute waren
sicherlich eher religiös konservative
bürger die verlangen natürlich die
härtest mögliche bestrafung der usa
wenn man mit eher moderaten redet dann
sagen die wir leiden unter den
wirtschaftssanktionen das letzte was wir
jetzt brauchen wäre ein krieg aber auch
sie sagen man kann die usa nicht einfach
so davonkommen lassen und sie verlangen
auch eine wiederherstellung der
nationalen ehre
die militärische führung reagierte heute
eher besonnen sagte man werde jetzt
sicherlich nicht überhastet und
emotional reagieren sondern sich die
antwort genau überlegen das ist eine
solche antwort geben wird das aber
scheint klar hat das vorgehen der
amerikaner das land eher hinter den
hardlinern vereint oder gibt es auch
noch andere stimmen naja ich glaube das
kann man für das volk nicht sagen es
gibt viele die sich einfach nicht trauen
kritik zu üben die erinnern sich noch an
die brutale niederschlagung der proteste
vor wenigen wochen
was die politischen lager angeht im iran
da kann man das glaube ich sagen und
zwar spätestens seitdem die usa im mai
2018 einseitig aus dem atom abkommen
ausgestiegen sind seitdem marschieren
religiös konservative hardliner und eher
moderat reformkräfte seit' an seit' es
wird spannend sein zu sehen ob das auch
so bleibt wenn es jetzt gilt eine
antwort zu finden auf die ermordung von
general so lehmann
vielen dank jörg nach teheran
us-außenminister pompeo hat derweil
kritik an der reaktion der europäer auf
die tötung soll ihm anis geäußert diese
hatten übereinstimmt vor einer
eskalation des konflikts gewarnt
pompeo sagte dem us sender fox news
briten franzosen und deutschen müssten
verstehen dass das was amerika getan
habe auch leben in europa gerettet habe
die europäischen verbündeten seien
jedoch nicht so hilfreich gewesen wie er
gehofft habe
spd-fraktionschef mützenich warf den usa
heute vor
mit der gezielten tötung des iranischen
generals das völkerrecht gebrochen zu
haben
dies sei kein legitimes mittel auch wenn
soli money für den tod tausender
zivilisten und die verheerung ganze
regionen verantwortlich sein
inzwischen gibt es auch eine debatte
über den bundeswehr einsatz im irak
grüne und linke fordern einen abzug
unionspolitiker lehnen das ab um ihre
soldaten zu schützen hat die bundeswehr
die ausbildung von sicherheitskräften im
irak erst einmal ausgesetzt
an den standorten touchy bagdad und
erbil sind derzeit rund 120 deutsche
soldaten im einsatz
ob und wann sie ihre arbeit wieder
aufnehmen ist völlig offen
cornelia schiemenz im german village
üben sie seit jahren den kampf gegen den
esc deutsche soldaten bilden im relativ
sicheren erbil kurdische peschmerga aus
doch seit gestern nacht herrscht
ausgangssperre
vorerst wolle man abwarten wie sich die
sicherheitslage entwickelt für die
grünen ein grund sich ganz aus dem
mandat zurück zu ziehen die
sicherheitslage und vor allen dingen die
politische lage im irak die hat sich
jetzt dramatisch verändert deswegen wäre
es unverantwortlich einfach so an diesem
mandat aus der vergangenheit
festzuhalten es geht hier um die
sicherheit von deutschen soldatinnen und
soldaten und deswegen sollten sie
unverzüglich evakuiert werden
der ausbildungs einsatz im irak läuft
noch bis ende oktober
möglicherweise müsste das mandat
überprüft werden wenn sich die situation
ändere so stimmen aus der spd
unionspolitiker wollen an dem einsatz
festhalten
deutschland hat nach wie vor ein
interesse an stabilität in der region
eine flüchtlingskrise hat uns genug
probleme beschert und wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass die menschen dort soweit es
irgend möglich ist weiter in sicherheit
leben können und deswegen ist dieser
einsatz der bundeswehr weiter sinnvoll
und
auch notwendig auch in der nähe von
bagdad bildet die bundeswehr irakische
sicherheitskräfte aus die linke zweifelt
am sinn dieser mission
man kann ja nicht sagen dass die mission
bisher zur stabilisierung beigetragen
hat wenn man eben eine ganz instabile
situation hat ich finde es nicht
verantwortbar
die bundeswehr auf diesem pulver fast
weiterhin zu belassen wenn einem von
denen was zustößt ist diese
bundesregierung dafür verantwortlich
trotz des vorläufigen ausbildungs stopps
will die bundeswehr in den nächsten
tagen routinemäßig und geplant weitere
soldaten nach irak verlegen der neuen
regierung in österreich steht nichts
mehr im weg auf ihrem parteitag in
salzburg stimmten die grünen für die
neue koalition mit den konservativen gut
93 prozent der delegierten waren für das
bündnis mit der vp für die grünen ist es
die erste beteiligung an einer
bundesregierung in österreich
grünen-chef kugler wird vizekanzler
vp-chef kurz bereits zum zweiten mal
bundeskanzler
australien bekommt die brände nicht
unter kontrolle
nun hat die regierung bis zu 3000
reservisten der armee einberufen um die
feuerwehr zu unterstützen und die
flammen endlich aufzuhalten
mehr als fünf millionen hektar land sind
bereits zerstört eine fläche größer als
die niederlande
die zahl der todesopfer stieg auf 23
schwer zu schätzen denn die folgen für
die tierwelt
experten gehen davon aus dass allein in
new south wales 480 millionen säugetiere
reptilien und vögel starben
wind und hitze könnten die lage weiter
verschlechtern
axel conrad
48,9 grad in pennewitz einem vorort von
sydney hitzerekord und der derzeit
heißeste ort der erde
während die einen die abkühlung genießen
geht nur wenige kilometer entfernt der
kampf gegen die tödliche feuersbrunst
weiter aber das schlimmste steht
offenbar erst noch bevor
wir haben derzeit 148 brandy von wales
aber vom süden her kommen starker wind
uns erwarten gefährliche stunden
wir fürchten dass noch weitere brände
ausbrechen und sich die situation
verschärft dabei sind schon jetzt viele
orte von den flammen eingeschlossen
immer mehr straßen unpassierbar
wir müssen den leuten jetzt sagen bleibt
wo ihr seid es ist nicht sicher die orte
zu verlassen straßen sind schon gesperrt
sie schafften es noch rechtzeitig raus
aus ihrem ort der schon in flammen stand
es war die schlimmste situation in der
ich je war
mir war es nur wichtig dass ich meinen
enkel heil nach hause bringe es ist
einer der größten evakuierungen in der
geschichte australiens feuer zerstörung
tote auch auf kangaroo island der
drittgrößten insel australiens von
diesem luxus hotel bleibt nur ein
gerippe aus stahl und beton
der nationalpark fast komplett
niedergebrannt
in diesem auto sterben vater und sohn
sie fuhren durch den brennenden wald ist
auch ihr fahrzeug feuer fängt
betroffen ist auch der bundesstaat
victoria dort in lakes entrance
beobachtet unser korrespondent normen
odenthal die lage und die sieht ja
irgendwie hoffnungslos aus normen wie
erleben sie denn die situation ja es war
in der tat ein weiterer schlimmer tag
mit weiteren toten wir haben es gesehen
und mit weiteren verletzten mit vielen
menschen die alles verloren haben und
auch mit vielen vermissten von dem man
immer noch nicht weiß was aus ihnen
eigentlich geworden ist also das alles
niederschmetternd wenn man etwas
positives sehen will und darum sind die
australier immer bemüht dann vielleicht
sowas dass man eine art von lern effekt
feststellen kann
bei vielen menschen die sich vor einigen
tagen das haben sie uns heute mal wieder
erzählt nicht hätten vorstellen können
dass sie alles zurücklassen sich dann
aber doch für die flucht entschieden
haben weil sie begriffen haben dass es
hier wirklich um leib und leben geht
runter die verstanden haben dass das die
einzige möglichkeit ist um das leben zu
retten die ihre sachen gepackt haben und
so ist vielleicht wirklich schlimmeres
hier noch verhindert wurden
es soll ja an diesem wochenende noch
heißer werden in australien das
verschlimmert wohl noch die brandgefahr
oder das ist so also es geht ständig der
bange blick auf die wetteraussichten wir
haben in den vergangenen stunden
wirklichen merkwürdiges erlebt wir
hatten gestern noch vor wenigen stunden
um die 40 grad jetzt sind die
temperaturen gefallen man konnte dem
thermometer quasi dabei zusehen
innerhalb weniger stunden um bis zu 20
grad ging es runter jetzt haben wir am
frühen morgen noch um die 15 grad aber
auch die frischen temperatur
mittlerweile sind keinen grund zur
entwarnung im gegenteil sie feuern die
brände brandherde weiter an
die temperaturunterschiede machten es
möglich dass die winde neu aufflackern
neu entstehen und dass das große problem
die winde die einfach nicht zu
beherrschen sind die funken die weit
fliegen die winde die ständig drehen
also damit hat die feuerwehr am
schwersten zu kämpfen und der aussichten
sprechen dafür dass das erstmal so
bleibt und dass auch die hitze hier an
diesem ort wieder zurückkehrt auch davon
ist die rede also es gibt keinerlei
grund zur entwarnung
trauriger aussichten vielen dank namen
guten teil wegen seines engagements für
die entsendung eines eigenen
flüchtlingsschiffs ins mittelmeer hat
der ratsvorsitzende der evangelischen
kirche bedford strohm morddrohungen
erhalten
er nehme diese zwar nicht sehr ernst
sagte er der augsburger allgemeinen
es sei aber wichtig sie konsequent
polizeilich zu verfolgen sonst bekämen
hetze im netz das gefühl dass ihre
menschenfeindlichen äußerungen salon
fähig seien kostenlos bus und bahn
fahren in der innenstadt damit geht
augsburg als erste deutsche stadt voran
und will so umwelt- und klimaschutz im
kleinen in die tat umsetzen
seit jahresbeginn kann man ohne ticket
an neuen haltestellen zu und aussteigen
ganz ohne fahrschein
doch der gratis bereich ist klein zu
klein main pendler aus dem umland sarah
schon berichtet ungemütliches
schmuddelwetter heute in augsburg viele
nutzen den regentag zum shoppen in der
innenstadt und freuen sich dass sie hier
jetzt kostenlos bus und tram bahn fahren
dürfen
aus berlin steht es super wenn wir bis
es so auch machen könnte immerhin 200
das sind die wichtigsten punkte die
damit bilden mit inbegriffen sind
ich find's super ist auch der umwelt
zuliebe toll
seit anfang des jahres hat die stadt
augsburg eine sogenannte city zone
eingeführt
rund um den verkehrsknotenpunkt
königsplatz waren kunden des
öffentlichen nahverkehrs ab sofort
umsonst
insgesamt umfasst der bereich neuen
haltestellen wir wollen damit den
parksuchverkehr in der innenstadt
verringern damit die luft natürlich
besser machen und es ist eine werbung
für den nahverkehr das vor allem an
eingefleischte der autofahrer bei bus
und straßenbahn ausprobieren können
für den übrigen verkehrsverbund brauchen
fahrgäste aber weiterhin ein gültiges
ticket kritik kommt vor allem von
pendlern von weiter außerhalb
es gibt nirgendwo dem
park-and-ride-platz wenn ihr auto stehen
lassen kann und dann günstig oder
kostenlos mit der bahn rhein fahren kann
das gibt es einfach nicht das ist nicht
durchdacht sein marketing effekt für
augsburg aber die praktische wert ist
relativ niedrig 20 gute sache guten
start aber ich hab das gefühl dass es
noch nicht weit genug geht eine
ausweitung ist allerdings eine
kostenfrage denn allein die neue gratis
zone wird die augsburger stadtwerke
jährlich rund 870.000 euro kosten
zumindest mal ein anfang und nun zur
vierschanzen tournee aber da ist ja
heute für karl geiger nicht besonders
gut gelang allerdings ins volk dritte
station da wurde er nur achter ein
herber rückschlag im kampf um den ersten
deutschen gesamtsieg seit 2002 sieger
wurde der norweger marius link vor david
kubatzki aus polen der jetzt die
gesamtwertung anführt
was für ein ärger platz 23 nach dem
ersten durchgang für karl geiger die
schlechtesten windbedingungen
wieder einmal hat es der bergisel nicht
gut gemeint mit einem deutschen paar vor
eaton
er muss das jetzt mal heute abend in
ruhe einordnen kann es noch gar nicht so
richtig beurteilen habe nach dem ersten
durchgang ist nunmal sich das ist
eingeschlafen
im zweiten sprung ist geiger wieder der
alte der oberstdorfer belegte rang acht
und reist nun als toni dritter nach
bischofshofen stärkste deutsche heute
stephan leyhe als fünfter bester
springer des neuen jahres bleibt marius
limbic der 21 jährige norweger feiert
nach dem erfolg beim neujahrsspringen
seinen zweiten tagessieg nacheinander
vor david kubatzki aus polen links im
bild der die gesamtwertung anführt und
nun als favorit auf den turniersieg gilt
zwei dreifach siegel für deutschland in
winterberg erst beim weltcup der frauen
im zweierbob ja und dann bei der
europameisterschaft der männer im
viererbob johannes lochner und sein team
holten sich zum vierten mal in folge den
em titel johannes lochner und seine
anschieber für ihre bauern christopher
weber und christian rach im zweiten lauf
hatten sie tatsächlich noch 15
hundertstelsekunden rückstand auf das
team von olympia sieger francesco
friedrich aufgeholt
rang drei ging an nico walters
mannschaft ganz gerne glauben mir ja
keiner job von den jungs ich glaube in
die geilsten fans überhaupt her daran
sensationelle stimmung und einfach
geiler tag
auch die deutschen frauen feierten einen
dreifach-triumph bei ihrem weltcup
rennen stephanie schneider und kira
lipperheide siegten mit 4 100 sekunden
vorsprung auf maria janka und patrick
platz drei eroberten die weltcup
debütantin laura nolte und deborah lebe
ja nun ist offiziell schalke torwart
alexander nübel wechselt nächsten sommer
zu bayern münchen
der 23 jährige wird dort hinter manuel
neuer die nummer zwei im tor
nübel wird bis saisonende bei schalke
aber nicht mehr die kapitänsbinde tragen
fünf tage vor dem em auftakt gegen die
niederlande heute das vorletzte
testspiel der deutschen handballer gegen
island die dhb auswahl gewann souverän
mit 33 zu 5
gelungener test der deutschen handballer
sie gegen island mit vielen positiven
erkenntnissen im tor andreas wolf mit
zehn paraden als mittelmann paul kruck
spiel und treffsicher im ersten
durchgang kapitän gensheimer gegen
anfangs starke isländer zur sicheren 16
zu 13 halbzeitführung nach der pause
wechselte der bundestrainer jugend
bitter im tor erfahrung und qualität
jetzt bringen die talente die isländer
in bewegung letztes tor durch johannes
dollar 33 25 noch einmal wird getestet
nächsten donnerstag dann der em auftakt
gegen die niederlande
ja und das zweite testspiel dann am
montag in österreich wir bekommen noch
mal schnee an den alpen und auch noch
mal sonnenschein wo das erfahren sie
gleich beim beta von resten telli so
viel von uns schön dass sie dabei waren
claus kleber freut sich mit dem
heute-journal team auf sie um 21 uhr 45
und wir sind morgen wieder für sie da
punkt 19 uhr einen schönen samstagabend
entschieden
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter das tief was uns
den regen und schnee gebracht hat das
zieht allmählich nach süden hin ab aber
in der kommenden woche da kommt von
westen her mildere luft an und die
temperaturen steigen weiter an
schauen wir mal in die nacht da gibt es
regen und schnee vor allem bis 400 meter
in den östlichen mittelgebirgen an den
alpen bis auf etwa 500 meter ja und im
norden klart es auf und auch der wind
der lässt allmählich nach und da wird es
kalt minus drei grad hier die tiefsten
temperaturen an der oder im vogtland -
zwar an den alpen und 6 grad sind es am
niederrhein morgen im tagesverlauf
einzelne schauer noch im norden sonst
ist es meist trocken und im osten sogar
sonnig an den alpen lässt der schnee
allmählich nach im westen gibt es
teilweise kompakte dichte nebelfelder
die temperaturen erreichen dabei null
grad im vogtland und 8 grad zum beispiel
am niederrhein und am oberrhein
die nächsten tage am montag wird es
neblig sein vor allem in der südhälfte
deutschlands im norden deutschlands gibt
es regen ein bis sieben grad und den
nächsten tagen wird es zwar milder aber
deutlich weniger vor allem zum mittwoch
in damit wünsche ich ihnen einen schönen
abend